This hateful son-of-a-birch is the deadliest
tree in the world.
The Spanish call it “manzanilla de la muerte”
meaning “little apple of death”, its scientific
name is “Hippomane mancinella” which translates
to “little apple that makes horses mad”.
But its real name is the Manchineel Tree and
it actually holds the Guinness World Record
for the world’s most dangerous tree.
The menacing Manchineel can be found in the
Caribbean, Florida, Mexico, and all across
South America.
The tree is like an angry pot boiling over
with hatred and childhood issues, life can
be tough as a young sapling you know.
Each part of the tree wants to kill you in
a different, agonising way.
The fruits it grows look like apples, smell
like apples and even taste like apples, but
they’re not apples.
Take a bite into a Manchineel fruit and you’ll
be like, this is alright, it tastes like apple
pie, but then you’ll be hit with an intense
peppery heat, that will quickly surge throughout
your entire body causing intense pain and
severe burning for hours.
Your internal organs will start to bleed,
your throat will close up, restricting your
breathing and then death will soon follow.
Phew that escalated from sweet to savoury
pretty fast, but here’s the worst part,
the fruits are the LEAST toxic part of the
Manchineel tree.
There’s a lot more ways this twiney twit
wants to turn you into driftwood.
The tree’s main source of poison is from
its deadly sap.
Its branches constantly ooze out a sticky
white substance.
If just a drop of this touches your skin it
will burn right through it like acid, causing
blisters and agonising pain.
If the sap gets in your eyes it can cause
permanent blindness and just like every other
part of this sadistic tree, if you inhale
it or if the sap enters your bloodstream,
it will kill you.
The aboriginal people of the Caribbean used
the tree to their advantage, they used the
sap of the Manchineel to make poison arrows
which were extremely effective.
Famous Spanish conquistador Juan Ponce de
Leon was actually killed by an arrow poisoned
with Manchineel sap.
During his final voyage to Florida to establish
a settlement, in a battle with the Native
American Calusa people, he took a Manchineel-poisoned
arrow to the knee, well it was his thigh actually.
He escaped the battle but died soon after
from the poison.
But you don’t even need to touch the Manchineel
tree to suffer its deadly consequences.
When it rains the sap is washed off the leaves
and branches and is dispersed all around the
tree via rainwater.
Therefore, if you stand under a Manchineel
tree whilst it’s raining your entire body
will quickly burn up and perish like every
talent-show winner’s career and you’ll
be left with blisters, burns and scars all
over.
Many beach going tourists have suffered horrific
injuries whilst seeking cover from the rain
underneath a Manchineel tree, unbeknownst
to its dangers.
Also, if you burn the bark of the Manchineel
tree the smoke that is produced is so toxic
that it will permanently blind anyone standing
nearby.
In fact, this angry wooden bugger is so toxic
that simply standing near it for a prolonged
period of time can cause serious injuries
and possibly death via asphyxiation, as your
throat closes up, caused by just breathing
in the tree’s toxic scent.
Something or someone has seriously ticked
off this psychopathic tree, it’s as if you
came onto its patch on Christmas day and slapped
it silly with its own sapling babies, it was
you wasn’t it, shame on you, you dirty tree-slapper.